okay guys have another evaluation Lorna
she gave me your data so let's kind of
dissect it she's 5 1 149 pounds 39 years
old not much weight loss she's tired
muscle pain she works out twice a week
boot camp and another workout spread out
so it sounds like it's pretty intense
she's taking one multi-mineral vitamin
and she's also taking magnesium and
potassium so I already know if she was
taking potassium it's probably 99
milligrams and just realized that that's
like a very a fraction of what a person
really will need they need 40 700
milligrams so all right when the morning
cheese that has a drink outside a
vinegar lemon drink which is really good
to take in the morning and then she'll
have a bulletproof coffee okay and then
sugar-free gum the first meal is at 12
o'clock she'll have three eggs four
pieces of bacon one teaspoon of butter
one slice of cheese one cup of spinach
okay
then at three o'clock she'll have some
coffee two teaspoons of heavy cream then
at 5:00 she'll have a kale shake four
cups with four strawberries now it's
seven she'll do to zucchinis and four
ounces of ground beef
okay now her ketone levels range between
0.7 and then 1 point 7 okay so point 7
is pretty small 1 point 7 is definitely
better okay now her blood trigger is
before the first meal is 84 so that's
pretty good it's actually perfect but
right before the second meal it's 94
it's a little bit higher okay so that's
all the data so a couple things I want
to mention if she's not losing much
weight and I'm gonna what the things
that jump out I would probably take out
the fat from the bulletproof coffee okay
just take MCT oil butter just take it
out and just do regular coffee with a
little cream okay other than that she
has this kale shake thing right here
right for four strawberries well here's
what we want to do
this is probably elevating the sugar a
little bit it's not a big deal but it's
raising up a little bit
I would probably if she wanted to do
this I would move this to seven o'clock
and then she'll basically have two meals
okay that's what I would do better yet
if she could do this I would take the 7
o'clock meal and push it back this way
that way we'll have a longer fasting
time period and a shorter eating window
that would be even better
but we want to kind of condense this
because we're this is gonna definitely
add like a little bit of a meal right
there I'd be nice to even take out the
strawberries if she's struggling with
weight loss and you could just put a
little more stevia in there some people
use the electrolyte powder I have or
even the lemon wheatgrass to sweeten it
that's one idea now at 3 o'clock she
needs a cup of coffee probably because
she's tired this right here will
definitely interfere with sleep now
you're just gonna find that you're just
not going to get the full rejuvenation
the full recharge effect which can
definitely affect your weight I would
probably cut this out if you want to
increase your energy maybe take some B
vitamins because one of the things as
you're adapting to a keto lifestyle and
you're tired is you need more B vitamins
like nutritional yeast very very
important and also realize this that key
to adaptation sometimes can take months
so don't always think it's a couple days
it could take actually months before
you're fully key to adapted and you have
to do this very disciplined and without
cheating okay because Jeanne will
definitely throw you off big time and
then we have muscle pain okay so this
can come from low amounts of vitamin E
so that's one thing you want to get a
natural vitamin E complex that will
actually help repair this but the B
vitamins might actually help as well
because B vitamins help get rid of
lactic acid and help the muscle recover
as well and omega-3 fatty acids will
also help recovery and I don't seem to
see any omega-3 fatty acids maybe in
this in these eggs a little bit but I
would have to kind of dig in and see
exactly what is in your multi
vitamin-mineral okay so no lorna go
ahead and make these changes and tell us
how you do
so we've been getting a lot of success
stories but I don't have your success
story yet so click the link down below
and upload you before and after I want
to actually hear about your success
story I want to see your
before-and-afters and every week we do
featured success stories so click the
link down below and share your success